okay today we have the pleasure of
chatting with james cooper he's a
filmmaker
he's an author he just wrote the book
kickstarter for filmmakers um we like
what we're seeing from james already
we're excited to have this conversation
with him today absolutely hey james
how you guys doing doing great how are
you
doing pretty good doing pretty good
keeping busy uh i'm in toronto so tiff
is happening right now so that's keeping
me pretty busy
oh very cool and also too you make comic
books or you do something yeah i write i
write comics as well as uh as well as
doing the film thing so
lots always to keep me occupied and keep
me out of trouble or in trouble
depending on how you like to look at it
well in
addition to your creative side you seem
very entrepreneurial where did you get
that is one of your parents a business
owner or did you just no i actually i
come from like a pretty blue collar
family like my dad you know he works as
a forklift driver you know for the at
the ford factory
uh and my mom's like a stay-at-home mom
like uh but it's funny because i've
always kind of had that like the
entrepreneurial thing like when i was in
grade five i wrote and drew comic books
that i i and i used the like the
school's photocopier and then i've sold
them like at lunch time at a little
table in the hallway
like oh so like it's always been like
i've always just kind of been doing
stuff by myself like it's it's never
occurred to me
like to just give my stuff over to
everybody else i've always just kind of
taken ownership of it and taken it the
whole way through myself
oh that's cool reminds me of stephen
king i think he said he used to write
horror stories and seldom at school
that's cool yeah i did totally dig that
you know james let's let's start let's
start with this book you know you know
you you had you crowdfunded for your own
short film and somehow
in the making of the film and afterward
you said you know what i want to go back
to and sort of write a book and explain
to other people lessons that i learned
along the way and some additional
lessons i've learned now tell us why why
did you make this why did you write why
did you write kickstarter for filmmakers
uh it's funny i'd never actually like at
no point during the process was i was
like oh i'm totally gonna write a book
about this because this is great it
never even occurred to me uh but we did
our we did our campaign for 45 days over
october and november
and when it was all said and done we
raised 21 000 for our short film elijah
the prophet
and when it was finished i really i
started to notice that i was getting
like a lot of tweets and a lot of people
were finding me on facebook and i was
getting emails from like friends of
friends and stuff and everybody was
wondering like if i had any advice you
know like on how or like give me give me
some info on like how you guys did this
or do you have any advice you know i'm
going forward with this thing in a
couple months and i want to make sure i
do it right and stuff and i was starting
to realize that there's there's this
knowledge gap like crowdfunding is still
new enough that not a lot of people know
a lot about it and so i realized like
somebody should be filling this gap like
somebody should be telling people you
know firsthand how to do this properly
because if you if you show up on
indiegogo you show up on kickstarter or
anything you know if you dig enough
there's a lot of really cool stuff there
um but there's also a lot of people are
doing it like so very wrong and that you
know and they just they see dollar
figures add up on other people's
campaigns they're like oh this has got
to be easy to do like look at how much
money everybody's making and you know it
doesn't help in like um i don't know if
you guys heard about uh the video game
company double fine
they uh they raised like 1.4 million
dollars or something like that for their
indie game you know back at the
beginning of the year and stuff and so
it's starting to gain a lot of traction
but not a lot of people know how to do
it right yet and it's kind of it's one
of those things where for the most part
you know up until recently it's been
trial by fire you only learn how to do
it by succeeding or failing sort of
thing
and so i just decided like i've got time
you know we didn't shoot the film until
like late march so we had time between
you know december and march that i i
just basically i spent like my down time
compiling everything that i'd learned
because before we launched our campaign
we spent two months
you know looking at other campaigns uh
and what they were doing and kind of
trying to fl finds through lines
basically between what was working and
what wasn't working and how people were
connecting to the campaigns
and how people were getting you know how
people were using outreach and social
media and stuff like that and we spent
like a pretty thorough two months trying
to put it all together before we
launched our own
and not a lot of people you know
are willing to or you know even
necessarily have the skills or the time
to go through all of that kind of effort
so i figured put it in you know a breezy
read that kind of breaks it all down
into basics and just throw it out there
for as cheap as possible
and just you know turn it into an
impulse buy and let everybody learn kind
of from what we did
and so during those two months of doing
research what were some of the things
that
really struck you either as a great
campaign or really poorly put together
campaign
uh i think great campaigns are pretty
thorough i think that seems to be the
really common element uh is that they do
a really good clear job of pitching you
what the story is
and then they do a really good job of
telling you everybody that's involved
because i mean for better or worse let's
face it crowdfunding as it stands is
lives and dies on a trust built
relationship
you know uh backers trust you to deliver
what you're at what you're promising and
the campaigner is trusting you to come
through with your backer with your with
your money because like kickstarter for
example um
the credit cards don't get charged until
the very end of the campaign
um
so if by chance you know you get a
couple big you know thousand dollar two
thousand dollar backers
and you know at the end of the campaign
their charge doesn't go through you know
you could be out a couple thousand bucks
that you really desperately need to get
the project off the ground so it's very
much about everybody just kind of
trusting one another
um and i find a lot of pla like a lot of
campaigns where they falter is they do a
really poor job of building that trust
they don't do a really good job of
pitching you what it's about and nine
times out of ten the only person you
even know and is involved with the
project is the guy pitching it to you
you know as you guys know it takes
dozens of people to get a film made but
you know for the most part like i'll
only ever know you know who the producer
is or who the director is
but how do i how can i count on
everybody else involved in this project
to deliver on their end who are these
people and that seems to be something
that for whatever reason like seems to
be left out of the equation in a lot of
these campaign descriptions and the way
that i like to think about it is if you
aren't at a place where you feel like
you're right you would be ready to go
out to investors you're probably not in
a place where you're ready to go out to
backers because they deserve the same
amount of respect despite the fact that
you may be asking them for twenty or
fifty dollars you know you should still
treat them as if they're part of the
process and they deserve kind of a
baseline level of respect
oh wow yeah that's great yeah great
point yeah i think that's something
we've seen and i don't know why it's so
frustrating sometimes when you see it
when
if you're going to take the effort to
launch a crowdfunding campaign
you would just hope to see that this
person is committed to what they're
doing you know like
if you're going to do the pitch video on
top of it if you're going to sort of set
a goal and say like look this is the
campaign like this
and it really becomes disheartening you
know there i am it's like a
screen freeze for a second there um but
but it's disheartening when you see that
that these people they don't put forth
the effort it's just like why are you
wasting everyone's time like don't don't
waste our time don't waste your time it
becomes becomes really frustrating when
we see that
yeah
and i mean you have to you have to i
think a lot of times like people just
see like that everybody else is getting
all of this money for their stuff and
they're like oh well i can totally do
that and they throw up their thing and
they're trying to get 10 or 15 000
and it and it'll be like oh i'm trying
to raise fifteen thousand dollars for my
first short
and it's like well wait a second how do
i know what how do i know that you know
what to do with this fifteen thousand
dollars if i give it to you
like you've never made anything before
how can i trust you
and i'm totally like you know there are
fantastic people out there that who will
you know they pick up the camera for the
first time and it's like second nature
then they know exactly what to do with
it and these guys may be fantastic and
they you know they may have the skill
set to deliver a really great first
short film
but at no point do they convince you of
that and that's where i think the
failure is is there's kind of a
communication
uh issue in some of them
can we talk about two people that have
trouble selling themselves because you
know some people aren't actors they're
not
front men or women you know they
wouldn't be the drummer in the band they
wouldn't be right
okay and and that's fine there's apples
and oranges in the world but i think
sometimes really
a good campaign needs sort of
faces involved so yes people have any
tips for shy people who are crowdfunding
maybe they're great artists and they're
very honest people but maybe they're
more shy and they don't want to put
themselves up put your producer in the
video okay that's good producers as as
in my experience producers tend to be
people like people persons
um and they're they're good at talking
they're good at you know pitching people
uh they're good in a room sort of thing
and they're they're used to being out
there you know and talking about
projects and getting people jazzed up
about it so if you can't put the
director you know for face forward on
the campaign you know let the producer
do it and then maybe just have like uh
or even just have the producer like
coach coach you
you know like
your your pitch camp your your pitch
video is not live
like my cam my pitch video like i shot
it here in my apartment and i think like
i shot probably five versions of it and
then i would cut it together and send it
to david the producer and we would go
back and forth oh this part's a little
too long this parts you know and then i
would just i would go back and do
reshoots of like our pitch video and we
went back and forth for a couple weeks
on it because we wanted to make sure we
got it right
uh there's absolutely no reason not to
do that
you know nobody's begging you to launch
your campaign but it's very easy to get
wrapped up in kind of the excitement of
you know it's right there it's you know
it's impending it's almost you know just
around the corner but it's so much more
important to launch when you're ready
than to launch when you want
yeah you know i i think just across the
board what we see is there's there's
just so many parallels from from making
a film to crowdfunding you know and
really if you if you want to succeed at
crowdfunding you have to treat it almost
like a film production and absolutely in
terms of the stages that you have to go
through you know like if you if you so
desire making a film you know one of the
best places to start is just being
involved
on on a film set you know and seeing how
someone else makes a film you know and
just gaining the experience and gaining
knowledge that way and that's why you
know we're big advocates for anyone who
wants to crowdfund don't don't just
start with your campaign get get
involved with someone else's campaign
and and and and advocate and promote
that and kind of see what it's like you
guys got to do your homework right it's
like anything
yeah yeah you know you know so yeah you
know yeah get buying someone else's
campaign first help them
you know help them create awareness help
them get backers on board see how
difficult that is
you know and then also learn from that
experience you know learn from the
messages they send out the engagement
that they're involved with that that
sort of thing well that's just it like
why make all the mistakes yourself when
you can watch other people do them
instead
you know take that the people are
launching crowdfunding campaigns
literally every day on kickstarter and
on indiegogo now like pay attention to
what they're doing see what works see
what doesn't you know
find out like people that are making
films in similar genres to yours how do
you know how do their descriptions read
how to what kind of stuff do they put in
their campaign rewards like there's
there's so many examples of people doing
this well now that it seems almost silly
to do it poorly anymore
and not only have you you know you
crowdfund all this money then you do
this book but then you're getting press
for the book you've been in what indie
wire you were on ted hope's blog
you other places so how is this
happening are you sending pitch letters
out and it's all yeah i wish i could say
that i had like a pr team or a publicist
or something that was doing this for me
and i got to sleep all night but it's
totally it's totally been just doing it
all myself um
which is you know simultaneously been
very exciting and very nerve-racking
because i mean i'm exchanged you know
i'm just this guy in toronto like with
this little ebook that i wrote by myself
and releasing it by myself and i'm
exchanging emails with ted hope and he's
like oh yeah let's totally put this on
my website and i'm like oh okay yeah
what
but it was awesome because like when i
went when i start really when i really
started to get the nuts and bolts of it
and finish the book i was like okay
now i have to actually release it you
know now i have to take that extra step
and start spending money on this thing
to pay for like the conversion services
to turn it into epub format and all that
kind of stuff i was like i hope somebody
out there cares that i'm doing this
because i mean i could otherwise i'm out
you know some money
uh but then like the whole thing's just
taken off in a way that i totally did
not expect
like it just i guess like the timing was
just right and like it seems to really
be catching fire and getting picked up
in a lot of places the response so far
has been fantastic people have been
dropping me tweets and on on email and
stuff just telling me that they've
really enjoyed the book and everything
and that's great like i'm really excited
about that
so just real quick james let's be clear
um so it's strictly an e-book um and so
far yeah it's strictly
i intend to do a print version before
christmas but right now it just exists
as a digital book
and and where exactly can people find it
let's just get that out there now oh
it's on i it's on ibooks it's on kindle
it's on kobo uh it's on nook
uh you can get it on like the sony
e-reader website like all basically all
the major uh ebook markets all carry it
now um or you can go to
kickstarterforfilmmakers.com
and there's a link for a pay what you
want pdf you can pay as little as a buck
for it or as much as you feel like it's
worth to you
and oh that's great no that's great and
generally how how much does it cost on
the various other platforms two bucks
oh wow wow yeah very cool and
do you mind i'm just curious um
how did you go about getting it on all
those platforms what was that process
like
it was actually a lot easier than i
thought um i basically i had absolutely
i've been making this whole thing up as
i go because i know absolutely nothing
about book publishing or anything uh so
i just i reached out to some friends who
who i knew like kind of had their
fingers in these types of things
um and they were like oh you should look
into this website called book baby and i
was like okay and basically it's it's a
paid service and they'll take your word
document or your pdf or whatever and
they convert it into the proper formats
for all these different stores and then
aggregate it to them
um and then up it goes like within i
think it's like three to six weeks or
something like that
and then um they have to they have
different packages that you can there's
like free ones where they take a cut of
every sale or there's ones where you pay
up front and then they take nothing um
and like they've got a bunch of
different services that's really cool
um and then they just they throw it out
to the you know to the ibooks
marketplace into the kindle marketplace
and all that kind of stuff and then
apple and amazon and all those guys all
take their cut uh and then the money all
comes back to you eventually i don't get
my first sales report until i think it's
like early november because of the way
like the accounting works so i still
have no idea if i've sold 50 copies or 5
000. um but the pdf sales come directly
to me so those are b those have been
doing really well so far so that's the
start
i'm wondering which chapter in your book
is resonating the most with people which
which uh the stuff that seems the stuff
that people seem to be really digging
is uh i do a thorough financial
breakdown of where all of our money came
from um on the elijah the profit
campaign uh the basically the latter
half of the book is is a case study
on our campaign and where the money came
from and how it came and when it came
um and like the number of campaigners we
had where like
which camps all the money came from and
that kind of stuff like really tried to
do as thorough uh a look at the process
from uh from what we actually did as
possible and that seems to be what
people are really jazzed about because i
mean you guys talk about this a lot with
your your goodbye promises campaign is
the transparency of it
um and how you guys are just putting all
the numbers out there and letting
everybody learn from what you guys are
doing
and so what that's basically what the
last half of the book is is i put all
the numbers out there this is how much
we made this is what amazon took from us
you know i personally raised this much
through my networks our producer raised
this much through his etcetera etcetera
and i put you know the the funding
campaign
uh charts that kickstarter gives us on
the back end those are all in the book
like
you can see literally everything that
we've got is in there um as as in as
thorough a breakdown as possible like
right down to like how much percentage
of our money came from friends or from
family or from strangers or from work
colleagues or you know from people that
we know strictly through social media
like i tried to break it down as much as
possible so that people could take a
look at it so that they know like what
kind of thought needs to go into these
sorts of things and not to take it for
granted um
and that a lot of people are also really
liking the
i have some charts in there i did a
really thorough breakdown of the
successful shorts and features campaigns
from kickstarter for all of 2011 and so
you can see
what by budget range like how many
campaigns were able to raise 7 000 or 10
000 or 20 000 uh for the features and
and shorts uh sections of kickstarter
and so that kind of gives people a
little bit of an insight into like you
know oh well i was thinking of trying to
raise 20 000 but only you know
13 people or whatever were able to raise
that much so maybe it's safer if we try
to do it for 15 because more people seem
to be able to make that much money um
and just kind of break it down so
everybody gets kind of like a snapshot
of you know what kind of
money is going into campaigns like this
right well forgive us james we haven't
fully read the book but i can tell you i
did go through different sections of it
and i really liked the part even about
the email and and you had a great point
and you said like nobody likes a bcc
email which we all know but i think
we think it's different when it applies
to us you're like
i really want to hear about what i'm
doing but it's very true and i think you
know you kind of allude to the fact that
people feel almost insulted by it and
it's a very valid point and i've been
guilty of sending those out um but you
talked about how really personalized
emails are one of the most effective
ways absolutely
they're they're really time con you know
they really suck up your time
but
it's worth it like the the turnaround
that you'll get from personal emails
versus the turnaround you'll get from
like a blanket bcc email it's worth the
extra time you know because people
people will read it because they you
know it's addressed to them you're
talking to them you know as opposed to
just hey guys i'm working on this thing
that you should all totally care about
you know and it comes off as very
informal
and you know people get enough stuff in
their inbox like that already and if
you're you have a relationship with
these people to the point where you feel
that you're able to send an email add to
them and let them know what you're up to
why not take the extra few minutes and
just write you know a two paragraph
email let them know what's up you know
and even if you want to like save
yourself some time do a general
paragraph about the film and what it's
about copy and paste that give everybody
their own opening paragraph
that'll cut some time out you know but
you still you still start off with
something personal and you know
you get what you need they get what they
need and you know just you know hope
that you've you hit a nerve in there
somewhere
totally and would you say just one or
two links in that email don't overwhelm
them with yeah just you just need the
one really like if well i guess it
depends on like how well you know them
like if you know them enough that
they've seen your work before that they
kind of know generally what you're up to
just send them the kickstarter link or
the indiegogo link or whatever like that
or you know send them that link and then
send them a link to your personal site
or your reel or whatever else you might
have but yeah you don't want to be you
don't you want to make it as easy for
them as possible so if they have to
navigate through half a dozen links to
get the full picture you're never gonna
you're never gonna get them right it's
always easier to say no than to say yes
especially when it comes to parting with
your money uh so make it as easy for
them to say yes as possible that's you
know one of the big challenges i think
that's great and just to clarify james
can you can you just take us the
timeline again in terms of
when you had the idea for the book and
then how much time you actually put into
the book i i just think that's important
to clarify
uh well we finished our campaign
november 26th
um and then it was probably like early
december by the time i started to
formulate the idea of actually doing the
book and kind of starting to break down
like a table of contents to the sort of
stuff that i would want to include and
then i worked on it pretty steadily
between then and like march and then
march and april were kind of a write-off
because we actually ran ran off and shot
the the film that we raised the money
for so i kind of had to chan you know
change gears for a little bit but then
by like may i picked it back up again
and probably finished it i would say
like mid to late june or mid to late
july rather and um and then basically
like had somebody proofread it um
a couple times to make sure that i
didn't sound completely and
then by you know by august i was getting
the files converted and stuff so on and
off more or less for about seven months
okay okay yeah i i just the thing i love
about this conversation right now is
just that you had this idea
and and and just the whole thing about
you're able to complete that execute the
idea and then just distribute it almost
seamless seamlessly online
um you know not too far from what we're
attempting to do here with goodbye
promise i just think it's wonderful that
you're able to create this product
and and with
you know a minimal amount of cost be
able to distribute it essentially
um you know it's essentially around the
globe isn't it you know yeah it's funny
that you say that last week i had a guy
email me like in the middle of the night
from australia
who had heard about the book and wanted
to review it for a website that he
writes for oh i was like what yeah okay
wow
yeah so like it's it's it's you when you
when you pay for these services like you
can you can put um
geographic restrictions on them like if
you only want it you know to release in
the states or in canada or the uk or
whatever but i just threw it up like
anybody anywhere knocked yourself out
like so it's available anywhere and
everywhere that you can access the you
know a kindle or an uh ipad or whatever
wow
and then the pdfs up there for people
that don't have e-readers like i really
did try to make it as easy to get to as
humanly possible um you know if you
don't have an e-reader you download the
pdf and you can read it on your computer
you know um so that you know or if
you've got a hundred e-readers you buy
the pdf and you can put it on all of
them because it's drm free there's no
copyright protection on it uh you know
just
to try to make it as easy as humanly
possible for people to get the
information because that's what it was
really about for me was to share the to
share the information i would never
expect to like i'm not expecting to sell
tens of thousands of copies of the thing
and get rich off of it which is why it's
only two bucks or why you can pay what
you want for it in pdf format it was
just like i spent seven months doing it
i might as well try and get something
back out of it
yeah sure well i'm wondering too what
are you doing now to market it or are
you kind of done with your marketing
phase i mean you've gotten it on
anywhere which is awesome ted hope's
blog and like i said a few other places
i think so do you spend time nowadays
marketing it or you kind of given in its
launch and now you're
you're on right now i'm actually
formulating phase two whatever that's
gonna look like um i'm starting to do
some brainstorming as to how to keep
kind of the momentum going on it um but
like the initial i think the great thing
about the initial push working so well
is that i have all of that behind me now
i'm not j you know there's there's a
little bit of credibility to the book
now that i can use to start pushing
ahead and kind of uh going through a
second phase of promotion and keeping it
out there and getting the word out there
to people that have kind of missed it
the first time around
well in in
keeping with that um wondering what you
think about our launch and please be
brutally honest no hurt feelings here
the pros and the cons where you see our
weak points and where you see our strong
points if you've had a chance to maybe
just go through our indiegogo page
anything that was a red flag to you or
you really liked
i honestly i think your campaign is
fantastic
okay um i think it's so cool what you
guys are doing because nobody has ever
done this before
and it's literally the first time i've
ever seen
a crowdfunding campaign that can't fail
it's kind of a foolproof idea because
you can't you can't fail like you may
not reach the million dollar financial
goal but really all you guys are trying
to do is get people to see the film
and it's working like you guys i can't
remember how you guys had like
1400 bucks or something last time i
checked which is a lot of people looking
at the movie already
and at the end of the day like no matter
how many people see it once the thing
once the campaign's finished you haven't
it's not that you've failed at getting
this many people to watch it it's that
you succeeded at getting this many
people to watch it and i think that's
really cool and really interesting uh
and you guys did a really good job i
think of of pitching it and you guys
have you guys have got a great social
media presence which you're leveraging
really well um i think you guys
really thought this through like
beforehand and actually i have i would
like to know like how you guys came to
the idea of like how this even like
to even think to use indiegogo in this
way
um you know this is not this is not a
short answer here
um you know we're trying our best we
have a we have a link up on our on film
prayers.com it's called like the past
you know 30 you know 30 days to 1
million or whatever and so we're trying
to share as much of this process as
possible um you know really it goes back
many many years before all this um just
making short films and working toward
um getting those short films seen um
whether it be on i film whether it be on
on um on youtube uh you know
yeah film festivals there junkies you
know like there's all these things of
just being a filmmaker just trying to
get your work scene you know and so you
know in that process we began film
courage and we started talking with
other filmmakers and learning their
stories and learning more about
distribution and learning more about the
business side of things
and and you know this isn't our first
feature this is our second feature so
you know we learned from taking our
first feature on the on
on the film festivals and and going that
route and and booking our own theatrical
screenings you know one-off screenings
and that sort of thing
and and we just saw how much how much
how much energy it takes how exhausting
it is you know because every time you
make a film you think like okay great
there's going to be
a distributor or some film or some big
film festival that just they just can't
wait to have your work and share your
work
and then you know as you get into that
process you're like wait a minute like
these big film festivals they don't
really care you know they have a whole
different slate of films that they're
looking to showcase it's not my film um
you know and and and dealing
theatrically with things it's not easy
to get butts in seats you know karen and
i we
we've hosted a screening series for two
years and we know how just how difficult
it is um trying to get people to come
out to see other people's small films
you know and it's not easy um so
you know we got to a point with with
knife for the wedding which is our first
film where you know it's on amazon now
um we didn't we also we didn't we didn't
pursue like
um a lot of distribution channels maybe
as as hard as we could because we were
still growing film courage
and and we were trying to complete
goodbye promise we thought hey you know
what if we can finish it by promise
instead of just pushing one film we'll
have two films that sort of that that'll
be available so we made the decision
instead of like going all out trying to
push knight for the wedding and trying
to gain distribution for that let us
just try to finish goodbye promise and
of course this whole thing is taking
much longer than we thought it ever
could so
um is that always the case though yeah
yeah so that's why it's just like you
know what are you guys doing so
um you know just keeping on keeping our
our our finger on the you know on the
pulse i guess you say and and just
paying attention everything and we've
learned so much so we're dead into so
many filmmakers that we've been able to
speak to for the last few years and just
hear their horror stories and hear their
triumphs and
and that sort of thing and just and just
and just gauging that along the way and
and really everything you're touching on
in terms of you're putting a lot of time
into the work and you just want to
figure out a way
so that people can access it you know
and you know another thing that we've
mentioned throughout sort of this series
that we've done
is that
it's really funny that that crowd
funding like the funding part of it when
you don't have the product that's become
more exciting than when you actually
have the product and you're ready to
release it you know it's like it's like
somehow when you finally get onto all
these platforms like itunes and and
amazon and distrify and
and vod and all this stuff you have this
platform and it works available but it's
hard to track down the actual audience
you know there's hard to engage with the
people that are actually um seeing your
work and experiencing your work and that
maybe you want to talk about it but you
it's hard to get at get at them so
um so there's just so many factors that
go into it that's why i say it's not a
short answer i'm just trying to touch on
some of the things here right
but we thought you know hey you know
what it'd be interesting
um to leverage some of the some of the
excitement we see in crowdfunding and
sort of take that and put it into the
release of our own film because at the
end of the day we knew we couldn't trust
film festivals we knew we couldn't trust
distributors we knew that we could trust
our own work you know so
we've been building film courage for a
while now and you know like but let's
just let's just try to reach people one
by one get people to see our work and
see what kind of opportunities we can
create that way because we believe
we believe in making the work accessible
excess especially for small films like
ours that don't have big name stars that
don't have a lot of resources don't
don't have a big budget and we believe
it we believe in sharing it and at the
same time empowering the audience
to see it and then if they like it to
have them share it because when you go
to film festivals on our side it's not
that we hate film festivals and and i
guess sometimes it appears that we have
this thing against film festivals no we
don't um we it's just it just kind of
slows down momentum because
when it takes a couple months to get in
the film festival and then it takes a
couple more months to get into that next
one there's
there's this dead period
where people aren't able to access the
film you know and and
well not to mention like after the
film's finished you know you could be
waiting months and months and months and
months for your first festival you know
and then by that point like your
momentum has come to a dead stop and
then you have to start at the train all
over again yeah sure yeah sure and the
actors and things that people that were
pushing it you know they're on to new
projects understandably so there it
loses part of your train
yeah
just you as the as the little drummer
boy or whatever
just keeping on and it's hard you can't
blame them because they've got to go on
other stuff well that's exactly it right
yeah and becomes you're you're the one
that's driving it yeah
but i think the exciting part is like
like you guys are showing with the
indiegogo campaign like it's becoming
it's becoming every day it's becoming
easier
for filmmakers to control the entire
process
um in the way that like we had a huge
boom in independent film in the 90s when
everybody realized oh i can do this
myself now you know we're seeing kind of
that exact same thing now
with distr on the distribution end and
soon like i think it's going to be the
norm that filmmakers just kind of take
the whole responsibility on themselves
instead of becoming one of hundreds you
know in a distributor's catalog
and you know like distributors are
fantastic and they what when they do
what they do
well it's a dream for everybody involved
but like you guys are saying like
there's they have certain expectations
and certain types of films that they're
after and
it's not necessarily gonna fit with
every single person's film so if you can
put kind of the destiny of the product
into your own hand there's something
very empowering about that
yeah yeah there sure is yeah that you
know and in that light you know i mean
it's
not that we have a
massive ego or anything like that but we
we just think with goodbye promise it's
a great way you know i think the film
and the theme of the film in terms of
a man that has this impossible dream
that he's going after um and the fact
that you know when we made the film we
didn't have anything when we started
it's like literally a zero budget film
um during production and then we were
able to utilize kickstarter to raise
post-production funds you know so
it it the whole thing represents sort of
like this this in-house production of
just having an idea going out and and
crafting the idea spending time on it
you know making the film and and now
with the release we have a way to
release it so yeah we've been able to do
all this in-house
and and so you know i guess it's
fantastic that's awesome yeah you know
so you know we just
i guess it's just um
i i i i don't know i don't know if i'm
putting it into words properly now but
it it is empowering and it and and
you know and we're sort of inspired by
it you know we just because we we feel
the frustration of so many artists and
so many filmmakers
you know because we we all go looking
for that entity to sort of discover us
you know that they're gonna sort of take
our work and take it to that next level
and and it doesn't happen you know we're
all kind of like chasing this this
this um you know it's for all of us it's
sort of this impossible dream you know
but you know if we can just
do something like this where we can put
the power in our hands and just push it
as far as we can
that's really a big part of what we're
trying to do here you know we it's it's
hard when you hear so many artists that
are frustrated by the system and no one
like sort of recognizing new
opportunities that were coming our way
and we felt we saw an opportunity that
we couldn't talk about we had to just
literally dive in and say look this is
an opportunity we see that we want to
make you guys aware of yeah
and nobody's nobody in the entire world
will ever be as passionate about your
work as you are
so
you
you know the people behind the
film make the perfect salesman
right like
you can find a distributor that thinks
your film's really cool and they want
you know they want to put it out to the
world but they will never work half as
hard as you will to see it succeed
you know they may have broader reach and
better resources but nothing beats you
know heart and determination when it
comes to the filmmaking process
and there's no reason for that to not
extend into the distribution arm anymore
yeah sure and i'm sure the same went for
your book probably putting it out there
and just well that's exactly it like i
never even for half a second considered
you know collaborating with a publisher
on it
like it didn't even occur to me uh
because i was like well why
the tools are out there now
like i've i finished it in july and it
was in it was in all the major online
retailers before the end of august wow
you know like if i had to work with a
publisher i'd still be working on it
editing it or formatting it or whatever
the case may be
and i would have to release it for 20
bucks because the publisher will need to
take a cut
um you know and
what am i i'm not going to get anything
extra out of it at the end of the day
now i control everything that happens
with it and i can push it out there as
aggressively as i want to
and there's nobody to tell me no yeah
right and i even heard something this is
going slightly off topic but like one
person had a book deal and then their
publisher said well we can't release it
until you get
ten thousand uh facebook followers so
they had like these social media
requirements
you the unpublished author need 10 000
followers for us to re to release a book
so that you have a following
yeah
i thought that was interesting so yeah i
mean but you're right and we've talked
about this and i know dave you came up
with this and that a lot of actors seem
to go that route they're looking for
someone to discover them where it seems
like more of the filmmakers are more of
the diy ethic and they're like no i'm
ready to do this myself and probably now
authors as well but yeah i think a lot
of us go by that old model of just you
know
you know star search hoping that
someone's going to to see us on stage
and go you i want you and then yeah
we're picked yeah well that's part of
it's part of kind of like it's part of
the dream they sell you at the beginning
right it's like you know you work really
hard and you put your work out there and
suddenly a man with a really big
checkbook shows up on your doorstep
and takes you off to hollywood you know
and well no that's not how it goes like
you've got to go buy the car get in the
driver's seat and drive yourself there
now that's the way it works that's the
new reality and a lot of people don't
have their license
right
no totally and or that we've heard so
many people say they just want to have
their people do it i know i'm a broken
record
but it's so many people so we admire
people like you james that just go no
i'm gonna do it myself yeah and and you
get results and you obviously have so
yeah it's really cool yeah and on your
side james um you know you said there
was some epub sort of conversion rates
that came into play in terms of your
expenses yep you know with the actual
release online with with the work you're
doing there are you can are you paying
for advertising i mean are there
additional costs that are occurring
along the way
not yet i've actually i've started to
consider the idea of doing some
traditional advertising um but right now
like just kind of the coverage the book
is getting has been acting
in that role like the articles on indie
wire on ted hopes blog and stuff like
that have all been kind of doing the job
of advertising for me up to this point
um but now that uh you know now that
that's all starting to peter down now i
think i'm going to start reevaluating
taking out some ad space you know in
this in some sort of strategic way like
i haven't really put a ton of thought
into it but it seems like the natural
next step
and have you considered what type are
you doing like the google ads are you
gonna do um facebook or do you have a i
have no clue i have it i like i'm gonna
do some research and kind of figure out
what's what will work best for the book
um and like in the same way that i've
kind of been making up everything else
as i go along like now i'm starting to
think about ads so now i'll look into
ads you know and maybe by this time next
month you'll see them on some websites
or on facebook or something i haven't
quite worked out the logistics of what
i'll do or how i'll do it as of yet
yeah i mean it sounds like one of the
next steps for you at least in terms of
the book to continue to get it to the
next level
would be you know obviously to
incorporate maybe some other um you know
filmmaker kickstarter stories or
crowdfunding stories you know some case
studies where you go in depth and sort
of pull out the numbers and the story
you know the one that you were able to
uncover with your own story you know
start doing that with some other
um campaigns that you see
the original the original the original
concept of the book
included like my case study and like
four or five other ones
um but i found like when i was starting
to approach people everybody was like oh
yeah i'd be totally down for doing that
and then when it finally came time to do
the nuts and bolts like answering my
questions and going through the process
and stuff they suddenly disappeared
um so in order to keep the momentum
going like i was like okay fine this
time out i'll just do my case study
because i can be as thorough as i want
and then i'll just release it and we'll
kind of take it from there and now that
now that this one's doing so well um i'm
considering either doing like a second
edition that has more
campaigns in it or just doing like a
book of case studies maybe like
you know just do like you know half a
dozen or a dozen case studies of shorts
and features uh you know from different
even not even necessarily just
kickstarter from kickstarter or
indiegogo or rocket hub or wherever just
find some interesting campaigns and at
different budget ranges at different
lengths
and just kind of see you know throw them
all into one book so you can read it
back to front and kind of in the same
way that we did our research before
launching our campaign see what worked
see what people would have changed you
know do it all in a convenient little
package instead of spending two months
scouring the internet for the answers
yourself
yeah
uh have people asked you to be on panels
yet i i see that coming have you already
yeah i was supposed to
i got invited to a festival in nevada
that was is taking place at the end of
september but it fell through uh because
they couldn't afford to get me there
um and i'm gonna be doing something i'm
gonna be doing something here uh in
toronto called transmedia 101.
uh they approached me a couple weeks ago
about coming by
um so that's going to be really cool and
while i was actually while i was writing
the book um i did a couple talks at a
place in toronto called the academy of
the impossible um who every once in a
while do an evening of talks feature
featured on crowdfunding and so i went
and spoke with them a few times and that
was actually really great homework for
me because i got to see the questions
people were asking and so i could
incorporate some of that stuff into the
book before it ever got released and so
i was able to answer some questions
people had you know that i didn't
necessarily think people would care
about or that i didn't even think to
answer
um and so i was kind of shaping the book
through that sort of stuff while i was
going through it
oh yeah i can imagine you'll probably be
definitely asked again maybe you should
put that out there on your website if
you haven't already just for for
speaking engagements in choir here you
know just yeah i've got that up there
yeah
because i think that'll work yeah i mean
and also what i love about that james is
here you are
um you you did the work and and you know
we have this new term that we've that
we've gathered gathered from filmmaker
gregory bain where he says don't be
capable yeah don't be cagey about
releasing the work
and i i think it's wonderful sort of um
these opportunities that are opening up
because you're just making your work
easy for others to to access you know
and and and that that's what's that's
what's really interesting about this
whole thing is i think for a long while
the attitude has been okay i have the
talent i have the skill i have you know
i have all this stuff and and someone's
just going to come along and discover me
and i think you know with stuff like
what you're doing and maybe to some
degree what we're doing it's like you
just do the work you know you make it
for easy for people to access and to
discover and then
that in itself can start to open up
these new opportunities um yeah well
ease of access is probably the most
important issue that faces
any creative artist filmmaker or
musician or author or illustrator
whatever it may be
because there's just so much noise out
there now you know there's so many other
things vying for people's attention and
for their money more importantly so if
you make it difficult you know to access
your content well goodbye audience
you know um which is why you need to be
doing things like you guys are doing you
know make it cheap make it easy to get
to you know uh or you know do you pay
what you want options like i did with
the pdf you know if you decide two bucks
is too much pay a buck you know like
make it make it impossible to say no
you know um and there's you know that
you you pay 60 bucks for a video game
you pay 30 bucks for a blu-ray or play
you know whatever amount of money for
whatever your your media advice is
if you can beat that cost you know that
the other guys are doing you know if you
do a vod thing and most people are
charging six bucks and you can afford to
charge 250. do it because why wouldn't
somebody pay the 250. you know uh but
too many people are oh no i know what my
work is worth and i know you know this
that the next thing well i've already
i'm already in profit on the book on pdf
sales
i have no idea what i've sold on ibook
and kindle and kobo and all those other
platforms but i'm already in profit on
pdf sales last time i did the numbers 86
of the people that bought the pay what
you want pdf paid more than the minimum
dollar for it yeah wow that's great and
you guys are seeing the exact same thing
on your campaign people are paying more
than the minimum that they have to
because people want to support the
things that they're interested in
you know i had a guy who
personally mailed me a check so that i
would email him the pdf of the book
because he didn't want the website to
take a commission
oh wow
you know like people people will support
you if you give them a reason to
and if you're but if like you guys said
if you're going to be cagey about it if
you're going to hide it you're going to
hold it in this little you know ball
over here and you're going to say you
need the key to get at it you know and
you hold it really preciously you're
just making it harder on yourself and
you're making it harder on them to get
to it and you know if they have to
travel a mile
and there's something interesting to
look at every 100 yards they're never
going to get to you right yeah i wonder
what you think about scarcity when it
comes to putting out your product like a
pre-screen um
right now they're you know no longer
sort of influx if they're in flux i'm
not sure what the situation is but they
had some beautiful movies on their site
and i believe what was the first
few days or weeks it was a certain price
and then it went up to like eight
dollars what's your opinion on that
i think it's definitely interesting
um i never i've like i've kind of kept
my eye on them but i never actually
they never actually had anything that
inspired me to actually take part
uh but i think the idea of using it as a
vehicle to kind of gain like to gain
that beginning momentum that you need is
pretty interesting
um because you could like if they had if
they had reached a a higher height i
guess where like being on pre-screen
meant something you know like in the
same way as being on netflix meant
something or you know that sort of thing
like if they had made it there
and then you could use oh we're on
pre-screen to kind of raise the profile
of your film before taking it to the
next level of distribution whatever that
may be vod or or online or netflix or
dvds or whatever uh i think it could
have really been a powerful tool for
people because it would have helped
generate early buzz and then once you
once you're past that platform then you
do whatever you want with it and you use
the kind of the the word of mouth that
you had from your pre-screen run but it
never seemed like it picked up the
momentum that it had the potential for
right right
i agree yeah no i i like that you know
and using this conversation as
inspiration here james um
what are you learning with the release
of of your of your book that you're
gonna sort of you know to think the
lessons you're learning that you will
then apply to the release of your short
film
um i think accessibility is probably the
thing that i've found is
for the book especially has been the
biggest benefit
um but also not being afraid to put it
out there like there's prob between the
excerpts that ran on indiewire on ted
hope's blog on your website
um and some stuff that ran on like john
rice's website and an article in
playback magazine like almost all of it
is taken directly from the book
like
with the exception of a couple articles
that i wrote specifically as guest blogs
it's all cut and pasted out of the book
so that you can see before you pay your
dollar or your two dollars if this is
the type of information you're looking
for is this what you want
you know in the same way that you can
cut together a two or three minute
trailer to let people know what your
film is about like people can get direct
you know there's probably about
i would say like
10 pages or more of the book for
available for free online
and some of it's the best information in
the book if
in my opinion anyway
um
but it's just like put it out there like
and people will
buy it you know or they or they look at
it and they don't want it and then they
don't buy the book and they're not upset
um but give them you know give them
enough you know especially because like
i'm kind of an unknown commodity like
um the book is unknown nobody knows
anything about this random book that
this dude from toronto released is it
any good i don't know two bucks is still
two bucks you know i could buy coffee
for that um
but if you throw it out there and you
give them as much information as
possible to make an educated purchase
then they're happy to
um and i think you see some of that
stuff on in independent comics actually
are really doing some interesting things
on the distribution side uh there's a
guy by the name of jim zub who's a
creator for image comics they're the
publisher that puts out like the walking
dead and stuff
um and he has
this really great series it's called
skull kickers and it's kind of like an
action adventure fantasy it's kind of
like a buddy cop story told in like a
dungeon of dragons universe um
and he releases a page of the book for
free every day online
on this website
and i he i'm pretty sure he did like a
blog post that ran the numbers and his
sales have increased since
like i think
i think you can get like the first
like the first five issue run
right now is available for free on this
website
but his sales have gone through the roof
as a result of it because people are
discovering it and then they'll buy the
back issues and then they'll catch up to
the recent stuff and now you've got a
regular reader
you know i think there's i think there's
things there's lessons to be taken from
stuff like that for filmmakers as well
you know like if you've got a short you
know shorts aren't necessarily they
don't people don't tend to to think of
them as having a monetary value because
of youtube and because of vimeo and all
that sort of stuff
but if you
you know if you put it out there as like
an sd you know a free sd stream for
example you know you can watch it on
vimeo or you can watch it on youtube or
something but you have like
a pay what you want download option for
the hd
why not put it out there it you know
this website gum road that i work with
on the pay what you want pdfs of the
book they take five percent of your
sales that's it it's practically nothing
um but throw your give throw link up for
a pay what you want file and you know if
if a couple hundred people pay for it
that's still more money than you were
going to generate before
you know because i mean how many people
do you know have sold their short film
for any significant amount of money
nobody really you know or the very rare
exception
uh so
why hold on to it why put it in that you
know in the cage
you know if you're if your worry is you
know that people like film festivals
won't program it
have a festival run first sure fine if
that's if you've decided that's your
best option go for it use that to
generate the buzz but then if you get
into a big film festival day one of the
festival put it online because people
are going to be paying attention to
what's happening at the festival and if
they can watch your film for free
you're gonna be the film they watch
yeah
and like um sundance is starting to
realize this and they partnered uh last
year with um i think it was yahoo and
they put up like half a dozen of their
short films for free to watch online
and like if they're start if like if the
big bureaucratic festivals are starting
to realize that this is a good idea you
know how are we the nimble independent
filmmaker lagging behind
yeah yeah yeah that's really true yeah
you know and yeah you know and and and
that light i mean that that's why you
know because when you look at what the
studios are doing you know they're
increasingly wanting to shorten that
window from theatrical to vld and sort
of
hitting the home market
and so that was also another factor for
us in terms of
you know you can clearly see the studios
are trying to do that you know and yet
here we are as the independents still
trying to play that game you know we're
we're still trying to to to to you know
we're slowing down our whole process by
by trying to compete in that theatrical
world whether it be
walling the film or whether it be the
film festivals you know it's just a
slower process you know that's the game
that they have the money and resources
for um
and we just wanted to use our own
nimbleness and and use the power of the
internet because the internet is already
viral it just waits for those stories
and those things that come along that
that help it help it showcase its power
well that's exactly it you have to play
to your strengths and if you've got a
film that you know costs five million
dollars and you've got some stars in it
there's absolutely no reason not to play
the studio game and to wait for the big
festival and to wait for the deals and
whatnot but if you're a small like you
know rock and roll indie film you know
that was made with you know more blood
sweat and tears than dollars you know
why not take the risks you know you've
been doing it from day one putting this
thing together anyway why not follow
through with it the whole way and see
what you can learn in the process
right and we're not waiting for any you
know advanced we're not we're not having
to get you know insurance we're not
having to do a lot of upfront costs so
it's it's an experiment and you know you
never it's tough to say what you know
from some of these distribution deals
that we hear about like it sounds great
and they get a great advance but what if
they had to pay in addition to that and
then where you know is there any sort of
balancing out or are they still in the
red so
yeah you know we'll see sometimes then
even though our numbers are very small
from what we've garnered so far from
this uh online release still it's it's
something and uh
it's it's been a process
and it's yours and that's pr that's the
important part is like nobody's taking
ownership away from you
yeah my cats
beautiful that's really cool that looks
like a big cat james you know he's huge
but living the good life
sounds like you're living the same world
we do in front of the computer with a
bunch of cats yeah that's it yeah
that's great um you know as we wrap up
james um you know any further um
thoughts um insights any feedback you
can give us in terms of what we're doing
um you know don't stop
i don't know what you guys have got like
i know you guys have got the indiegogo
campaign but i have absolutely no idea
what phase two looks like for you guys
as far as like how you plan to keep the
momentum going once the campaign closes
down
but
you know keep going don't stop find any
avenue you can to keep the film in
people's eyes and to make it as easy to
get to as possible um there are a lot of
really great books you can read um sell
your sell your film without selling your
soul by the film collaborative
and think outside the box office by john
rice
are both really great diy solution
uh books
um sell your film without selling your
soul especially has a lot of um
company names that you can look into who
handle
kind of uh the service end of dvd
distribution and stuff like that but
like word like they don't buy the film
from you you hire them as like a service
company
and then you guys split the profits and
they aggregate to amazon into walmart
and all those sorts of different places
that might be the sort of thing you want
to look into if you're looking to get
get it onto physical media um look into
gum road which is where i'm doing the
pay what you want pdfs that might be a
cool option for you guys uh to kind of
keep really with the rock and roll vibe
of your campaign
um
and just explore like see what's you
know see what's out there in terms of of
distribution options because the
internet is blowing the whole thing
blown the lid off of the whole business
model
and there's still a lot of places that
people aren't you know there's a lot of
rocks people aren't looking under
yeah that's great advice gum road y'all
have to look at that yeah
you have any last thoughts
um just excited to see the the second
phase for you i'm i mean i'm just i'm
i'm inspired by what you're doing and i
think it's really cool and um and and
just curious you you were in film school
and you dropped out in 2008
yeah i was there for
eight very brief months
okay and what was your turning point
what did you say you know
this isn't going to take me where i want
to go
um well i started in i started at the
school in july of 07.
um and in may of 008 i uh was accepted
into an internship program in can
uh at the american pavilion and so i
left i left school for a few weeks to go
do that and in the three weeks that i
was in can you know the two weeks of the
festival uh i learned more about the
business of film
than the entire seven months i'd been
into the program and i realized at a
certain point like
none of these guys are going to be able
to take me much further than i already
am so i took a bunch of their equipment
made a couple short films and then got
the hell out of there before the second
half of my student loan went through
wow
and so while you were in con what what
was it that was like that trigger that
this is where it's at not what they're
teaching me about
theory or i don't know i've never been
because i think i think the one thing
that'll well not the one thing there's a
lot of things but one of the things that
a lot of prospective filmmakers tend to
forget is that it's the film business
not the you know not the film art
you know it's a film business and
business is just as big a part of that
uh model as film is and if you don't
know anything about the business end
like you're gonna be dead in the water
because at the end of the day you need
to be able to
somehow sustain a career on this
um and you're not going to do that being
ignorant about the financial side of
things and so that's what i was learning
a lot and can like i would spend a lot
of time in the marche in the underground
of the lumiere and just walking through
it's it's basically it's a trade show
for film distributors they're all there
with one sheets and uh you know a
trailer playing on an hdtv and they're
trying to sell you their films in
different territories and stuff so i
just faked my way through it i'm like
half you know halfway through my film
school program you know i've got on my
suit and my tie and and i'm no
different than anybody else there
because they don't know the difference
and i just walk through i'm like oh what
do you got and just listen to them sell
me stuff
i'm nobody but they don't know this
and they're talking to a million people
a day so they don't really care who you
are you're in there so they assume you
belong and so i was learning so much
about how to sell people on my ideas and
you know what's working where it's
working and how to how to kind of talk
the language
and
at a certain point i was like when i go
back to school like they're just gonna
put me in a studio and be like here's
your hdv camera guys go nuts
and i was like
i don't want to go back to that like i
want to keep going forward and after
being there it felt like it felt like
like cutting off the
snake at the head and kind of waiting
for it to grow back like well i sat in a
classroom and so i had to i had a couple
short films that i had made and just
basically took those and ran
interesting wow yeah that's really cool
well i james you know we want to thank
you for taking this much time out of
your schedule we know that you're
contacting us from toronto from the
toronto international film festival and
so you know continue to enjoy your time
there um i find myself really charged by
this conversation and by and by the
information that you're sharing with us
the the things that you're doing
um
yeah you know it just it also validates
sort of our own path so thank you james
yeah thank you thanks so much for having
me it's been awesome
cool and then when we put the the video
up we'll put the link um to your
article on our site that has the first
you